we're just hearing there from professor
peter openshaw really sounding a warning
that the next few days could be critical
when it comes to suppressing at levels
of the virus
and do you think more restrictions need
to come in
well i think the country will have been
watching with concern
as the r rate was confirmed as over one
on friday and as the number of cases
has risen quite significantly this week
um i think that was
relatively inevitable when the
government were encouraging people to
go out um back into restaurants and pubs
to eat out and to
and to get back um socializing to go
back to work and of course
as millions of children rightly have
returned to school over the last couple
of weeks but what's
really important and what should have
happened to underpin
that returning gradual returning to
normality
was an effective and mass testing system
an effective track and trace system and
the financial ability for people
to self-isolate now we've heard this
week about the many many people that
have struggled to get a test here in
sheffield
over a number of days there wasn't a
single testing appointment
appointment available and i knew of
constituents that were being told
to go into areas that are currently
under lockdown to travel up to scotland
up to the north east
that's completely ridiculous to be
asking people to travel around the
country that are
potentially infected in order to access
tests
so it's um it begs belief really that
when the government had asked people to
get out the house go back to work go
back to school
that they hadn't put in place that
testing capacity in order to underpin it
and to make it safe
that's what's really important now not
necessarily restrictions although we
have supported
the government's return to the rule of
six but in order to make sure that we
underpin a safe
return to work uh and to um slightly
towards normality that we have that
testing regime and track and trace that
underpins it
uh okay and it's interesting to hear you
say that you know you do support
the kind of return to normality if you
like as far as possible so does that
mean that actually
you think the government's got it about
right with opening pubs restaurants
trying to get the economy moving again
well look of course we need to keep the
economy moving and and keeping the
economy moving is not a mutu
it's not at odds with um protecting
people's health because we need
um the economy uh to be functioning in
order to fund the health service and to
make sure that the nhs is as open
as possible but these measures need to
be kept under review
at the moment it appears that
transmission is happening
in households but of course if people
aren't accessing tests
and we know that many many people aren't
you know the fact that there wasn't a
single test
available in sheffield suggests that
it's far greater than the 10 of people
that the government
are suggesting at the moment then the
fact is we don't know exactly where this
transmission is happening
so we need to get that testing system in
place in order to understand exactly
what is happening with the virus
and then all these measures need to be
kept under review we will support the
government
in the in restrictions and in measures
that they take as long as they are based
on evidence and sound medical advice
at the moment we can't know the full
picture because they have not got the
testing capacity in place
interesting to hear about the situation
where you are in sheffield now i want to
move on to brexit because
there's been a lot of movement should we
say on brexit uh in the last week and of
course there'll be even more
next week when the internal market bill
comes to the house of commons now
kirsten has written for the sunday
telegraph uh this morning saying that we
should get on with brexit so we can
focus on defeating coronavirus
i mean it's pretty easy to throw around
these slogans isn't it get on with
brexit let's get brexit done
but i'm just interested in what that
actually means
is labour effectively saying then that
the government should compromise
on the two outstanding issues that
preventing a trade deal right now so
would labour
support the government rolling over
on fishing and also on state aid
well um kierson as you say has written
for the telegraph to say that
boris johnson's actions and the
government's actions this week
completely compromised progress towards
securing a free trade
deal with the european union what
they've done by picking up you know that
the things that are
that we know uh forgive me that some of
the things that are holding up the trade
deal
are on fishing and on state aid so in
order to get brexit done is labour
saying that the government should
compromise on those two things
well the point is sophie that these
issues are not insignificant and they're
important they're important to slaves of
our economy but they're certainly not
insurmountable
and what's baffling about the
government's approach is that it there
was every
um every prospect that those issues were
going to reach agreement in the joint
committee this week
and it's really important that it is
through that joint committee between the
uk
and the eu that that agreement is
reached that was the that was what was
put forward in the withdrawal agreement
and indeed in the northern ireland
protocol what would say on state aid
is this the government has not used its
ability to spend
on state aid even whilst we've remained
in the eu
so to the idea that we're picking a
fight with the european union on this
and potentially undermining the prospect
of
securing a trade deal is quite frankly
baffling when they not even
use their the ability and their
potential to to spend on state aid
whilst we've been a member of the
european union
look boris johnson's and his
government's actions are seriously
undermining
and jeopardizing the chance of securing
a free trade agreement with the european
union it's unilateral approach it's easy
to criticize the government and the
negotiating tactics and certainly you
know when we talk to robert buckland
we'll be going over whether or not this
was a
sensible move for the government to do
but i just want to go back to the
fundamental
point because it's very easy to say
let's get brexit done let's get a trade
deal
the two outstanding issues are on state
aid
subsidies and on fishing and i still
just don't understand whether or not
labour would compromise on those two
things
well sophie the protocol states that
state aid will apply
um to northern ireland that is what the
pro that is that is where the agreement
um that is what that was what was agreed
that was what was negotiated that was
what was written down and ratified into
international treaty
by boris johnson that has already been
agreed that so you're happy then with
the
existing deal even though you voted
against it you said it was a betrayal
we didn't the reason we voted against it
wasn't because of the northern ireland
protocol we have always supported
measures in order to protect
the good friday agreement and to avoid a
border on the island of ireland
the protocol was designed in order to
uphold that good friday agreement and to
preserve
peace and prosperity in northern ireland
we didn't oppose
theresa may's deal on the basis of the
backstop nor did we
oppose boris johnson's deal on the basis
of the protocol
what what his actions now are doing is
undermining
the protocol and necessarily pushing the
conversation
back to the border on the island of
ireland that is seriously
um risky and undermines all the progress
that has been made
since the good friday agreement so
kierst almost says he wants to you know
stop banging on
about europe labour now saying that the
government shouldn't be rowing back and
trying to override a withdrawal
agreement that you voted against and
thought was a bad deal at the time
isn't the truth of it that actually
labour is really acting in its own
self-interest here you just want to stop
talking about brexit because you know
that that would be the best thing for
you politically
well i think the country wants to stop
talking about um brexit um you know and
the people of northern ireland
um many different people across
communities that i've spoken
to are looking upon this incredibly
wearily
that these issues that we were told were
settled are now being reopened that
wounds that we thought were healing
and now being reopened and that the
government are unnecessarily inflicting
this
again on the country and quite frankly
this is the last thing the country needs
right now
as we're attempting to respond to covid
and cope with economic recovery
what we need is a deal with the european
union that protects
our trading relationship protects
businesses protects jobs and protects
peace in northern ireland what boris
johnson is doing
is risking all of that and it's as i say
the very last thing the country needs at
this critical moment
you know we've left the european union
on the 31st of december the
transposition period will end
we'll be stepping out onto the world
stage on the 1st of january
as global britain for the first time in
40 years as
non-members of the european union why on
earth
would we be stepping into that next
chapter of our history as the united
kingdom
undermining our reputation as a country
that respects its word
and upholds the international rule of
law okay
now we are out of time but i just want
to ask you just very quickly
uh to comment on the government's new
sentencing
uh policy so at the minute you can only
get a whole life sentence if you're over
21
they want to say that if you're between
18 and 21
you should be able to get a whole life
sentence is that something that labor
supports
well look we'll um we'll review the law
when it comes forward and we'll consider
um whether or not to support it then but
uh you know and i hope that robert
buckland
addresses this later i think what's
important to note is that the criminal
justice system
is in complete disarray because of um
years of
cuts of privatization the probation
system and of undermining
of the courts and of the police so you
know there are many issues with the
criminal justice system
the length of sentencing is is quite low
down
the list of issues that faces it at the
moment